i work as a human robot interaction
researcher whoa i'm sorry a human oh i
thought you said human robot you mean
human slash robot interaction researcher
that's what you mean right um
actually that's a very good sort of
take on it because i do get to research
how humans behave and also get to work
on robots right how to design robots so
they can interact with humans yes yes i
i guess when you first said it it
sounded like i'm a human robot
uh interactions person and i thought
what's a human robot i've only met one
and his name is jordan schlansky so uh
that took me back a little bit but uh
but i see it's so you work on how to get
robots and humans to work together
essentially is that true exactly that's
it do you design robots what kind of
robots do you design that's a very good
question i can actually show you uh for
the listeners who cannot really see what
i'm showing conan well i'll describe it
it's a uh hold it up uh let's see or or
push oh look at that
wow he's pretty buff that is a very
muscular uh it's it's white it appears
to be about three and a half to three
and a half feet tall or four feet tall
it's uh quite muscular
white robot with a screen for a face it
looks like it's wearing a space helmet
and um it's really cute actually what's
the name of that robot so the name of
this robot is cutie oh cutie oh
hi cutie how are you do not call me
cutie
my name is tuffy don't listen to it
i hate it when people call me cutie
that's
that's sexual harassment i'm suing all
of you bleep bleep all of you
wow oh well cutie did you build cutie no
so i did not physically build the robot
this is a consumer robot that i'm
working with and i'm designing software
and i'm designing interactions that this
robot can have with people so that robot
oh i see so
your job is to figure out how can i get
this robot to interact with people as a
companion is that the idea primarily
exactly that's what i that's what i tell
people that this is a tabletop companion
robot so you can see it's a non-mobile
robot it does not move around it's
supposed to be stationary at a place and
then it can move it can move its head it
can wave its arm and it can just like
talk and interact with you what
now do you think in the near future we
will be interacting with robots we'll
have robot friends robots that help us
do things robots that because that was
always the dream that was promised to us
when i was a kid in the 1960s and 70s
they said oh there's going to be robots
and you're going to be able to play with
them and be friends and then all we got
was these goddamn laptops
and
and iphones and it's like screw that
noise i want uh a robot that will play
with me you know you're always thinking
ahead of others i believe um thank you
uh i i appreciate and i really
acknowledge the intellect and the
smartness that you have conan always
been a huge fan of that i really mean
you know can i can i say something not b
whoever programmed you did a beautiful
job
because i i love everything you just
said uh and and whoever
my hats off to your manufacturer
exactly
i think cutie just moved and came awake
dude it did oh look
you know it's funny
look it's making a little wake-up face
it is
its screen is animated and it's got cute
little eyes and you know what's funny it
woke up just as you were praising me and
in the background it started rolling its
eyes
the robot actually said what a load of
horseshit
oh no abby cutie has a knife
abby i this is a concern uh do you ever
worry that cutie will rise up and
destroy you his master that's uh that's
something that i was thinking you might
bring up
uh but i'm not scared of qt at all look
at it look at you do you want what that
can it do um it doesn't overwhelm that's
that's the dumbest thing you'll ever say
of course he can rise up and destroy you
they always start out looking cute you
know hal in in 2001 looked cute um
don't be deceived by cutie i would make
sure that he is unplugged when you go to
sleep at night i would make sure that
look how cute terminator was are you
even wasn't there like a movie
the doll chucky from the movie wasn't
that like
a robot sort of no he's not a robot he's
the possessed soul of a serial killer
yeah and also he doesn't look cute he
looks like me and adolescence so uh
uh don't be fooled no i just think you
should cutie right now is standing
behind you and blinking and doing his
best to look like a happy-go-lucky robot
but we all know that this ends very
badly yeah so it's been nice
talking to you i think you've got about
a month to live